good morning reg how are you that's up
for debate I know you just start getting
over a little setback with your kidney
stones and so forth but you still have
that jumper Theodore I know I know you
know I have my shot is not affected by
my kidney stones not at all no no it's
it's like every day is the Jordan flu
game for me I just continue to come in
and continue to perform in a high level
my shot is actually immune to any any
diseases I was ice snarky on Friday
night with LeBron and the Lakers in the
Mavs when I sent you that text and said
this is why LeBron is better than Kawhi
after the triple-double because most
people don't understand our relationship
because we've known one another since
the early 90s you know so you and I have
had this relationship for quite a quite
some time now where we would text one
another on certain sporting events and
voice our opinion strong opinions and
you text me and was like this is why
LeBron
when we were alluding to that overtime
game versus the Dallas Mavericks yes
show that LeBron and Anthony Davis put
on versus Luca and porzingis and the
Dallas Mavericks
and though I'm with you most of the way
my point is this with Kawhi at this
point time of their careers collide
getting it done at both ends of the
floor
not to say LeBron doesn't take moments
during his 17th season to get after it
defensively but why is doing it on a
nightly basis and he's younger so you're
asking who the best player is today
between the two we've seen last year
without a top 50 player and I alluded to
you this to win a championship without a
top 50 player that's what Kawhi did
right yeah
LeBron is point with the top 5 player in
Anthony Davis well
yeah but prior to that people didn't
include Anthony Davis as a top-five
player all of a sudden he goes yes they
did not okay if I put let's start here
you got LeBron Greek freak
you got Kawhi you got Steph Curry you
got Kevin Durant so I've already bumped
him out of the top five so let's stop
with this he became a top five player
all of a sudden because now he's with
LeBron he was a great player we've
rediscovered Anthony Davis okay one of
the best young two-way players couldn't
stay healthy he couldn't stay home right
that's right but but constant all-star
game and constant all defensive team
okay first a second team right or wrong
right but we forgot that how good he was
because he's been injured and he was in
New Orleans now all of a sudden he's in
Los Angeles now we elevated him to a
top-five player in the game that's
revisionist history here and and I'm
just saying he is he a top 15 player
absolutely
maybe he's top 10 he's been inconsistent
because he's been injured but LeBron has
got so there's no excuses for LeBron and
no excuses for Kawhi cuz Kauai has Paul
George right so he has not played with
Paul George this year you will see that
okay but he will at the end of the year
if these guys both play then there's no
excuses for either one of these guys on
how far their teams go with their other
their sidekick here absolutely okay and
I hope and pray look I know it's a long
season injuries are a part of it
Denver will have something to say about
this I think Houston will figure it out
as time goes on so those two teams will
have something to say about this but the
clear-cut favorites in the in the
Western Conference right now right now
are the to LA teams and we smoke we keep
talking about this and this is the best
thing that has happened to the NBA in
15-20 years is to have two teams playing
in the same building with four
superstars but why does the younger
player Kawhi need more load
management then the older player Oh
Benji
15 his being in or what core sure when
he's all check and sexy yeah doc crib
hold on hold on reg like I got a get a
phone lines breaking up a little bit
there just when I hit him with the
hammer there convenient yeah Kauai the
youngster needs load management here
Reggie was doing that move from spies
like us with Chevy Chase or they and I
think quite you know think oh and we had
phone issues yesterday and Todd is gonna
try to reconnect yes week love that was
getting good too
I was enjoying that okay why does the
young guy need load management in Kawhi
Leonard because he wants to play with
his kid when he's older LeBron wants to
be in the NBA when his kid gets old
enough here's the thing and you and I
somewhat agree Kawhi will not have the
numbers in the years and the games at
the end of the day that LeBron will have
yeah but I told you this Kawhi will have
as many if not more championships than
LeBron that means and that means he will
have to have gone through him to win
those championship ick up right now I
give you first pick between Kawhi and
LeBron we're just playing one who can
Kawhi Leonard okay I'm gonna take LeBron
and then my second pick is but you I'm
giving you first pick and then I get two
picks so you would go with LeBron and I
can't do Kady right
I can't you pick what you pick whomever
you want to pick okay I got a healthy
Kevin Durant and now do I get to pick no
no no it's I get two now back you get to
bump the
you your guide Kauai so I got I am going
to go with a healthy I would go with
Yanis oh okay I thought are we gonna
sneak that one in on you okay
well I guess I've got to take one of the
five best players in the game and I have
to take Anthony Davis along with Katy
and LeBron you're not gonna be able to
deal with let's go let's see I'm gonna
take Steph Curry and I will take James
Harden good luck with that
okay good luck with that with your left
with your guy with the broke left hand
well no no these guys are all healthy
[Music]
Luca John chick oh that's a great pick
by the way that was a great sneaky pick
[Music]
who you taking I will go with just
because you're disrespecting me Butler
I'm not disrespecting him he's saying
others are why is he such a drama queen
Jimmy Butler is a very good player he's
not a great player he's very good right
and surrounded by the right pieces which
i think is the infrastructure in Miami
with Colts rolster and Pat Riley I think
that was a perfect for him I think look
people are looking like why would he
leave Philadelphia like they're looking
at the trail that he's left in Chicago
then in Minnesota
then in Philadelphia they're like
something's got to be wrong with them
there's got to be some type of baggage
all he does is show
play hard and hold his his teammates
accountable yeah right that's what you
want in a leader on it I could play with
Jimmy Butler all day long but he's not
gonna carry my team he's not a he's not
a great player he's a very good player
on my team I already have great four
great players I need someone that's
gonna balance it out that's why Jimmy
Butler would be my fifth okay all right
fair enough
four more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]